indeed thank you trace a new weekly jobs
report is out this morning showing 837
thousand americans filed for
unemployment claims last week
that is a big number but it is less than
what was predicted by analysts and it is
an improvement from the previous week
the dow is reacting opening higher this
morning as we head into the final
quarter of 2020 october 1st here we go
down to 165 points
let's bring in jason furman former obama
economic council chairman
and professor of the practice of
economic policy at harvard
jason always appreciate having you on on
the program you always bring a very
unique
perspective first to that new number on
the economy what does it tell us
837 000 filed for unemployment claims
last week and i can tell you that that
is now the lowest that they have been
since the pandemic struck the economy
back in march
yeah that's a lot better than we were in
march
it's also very high relative to anything
we ever saw
before march this is a number you would
normally see
in a pretty bad recession so a lot of
people are still losing jobs
but a lot of people are still gaining
jobs too the economy is just
very turbulent so i'll reference back to
a conversation you and i had back in
april and again in may um we were
talking about you
meeting with a a i believe as a zoom
meeting of bipartisan
business leaders where you suggested
that we are going to come so
sharply out of the economic depression
from this pandemic
that it is going to benefit donald trump
near election day
so based on the number that we just put
up on the screen better than expected
certainly showing some promising signs
of a recovery
do you still hold that that theory that
the economy is recovering so sharply
it'll benefit president trump in the
election
yeah i mean my view is that the economy
would recover
very sharply but the recovery wouldn't
get all the way there
so on election day donald trump's gonna
be able to say look at the millions and
millions of jobs created
and joe biden's gonna be able to say
look the unemployment rate is you know
eight percent or whatever we find out
it'll be tomorrow
i think both sides have a good argument
i think that's probably why no one's
voting
overly um you know on the economy right
now and there's so many other issues
you know obviously obviously the the
trump campaign the white house can make
the case and this is a pandemic
and this is a very unusual historic
circumstances for
our economy so it's it's important isn't
it to take into account
where the economy was before the
pandemic hit pre-pandemic under the
trump administration five and a half
million jobs were added
we go back to the obama economy 1.2
million jobs were added
in obama's first term in office so by
comparison isn't president trump
doing better on the economy than the
obama years
i mean that's a pretty absurd comparison
when
there were eight hundred thousand jobs
lost in february 2009 i'm not sure that
was
barack obama but you're comparing the
pandemic soy
i thought it was fair but i mean i you
know i think it's a little bit silly to
play these games because so much of what
goes on in the economy i think is about
american businesses american workers
um but if you want to play you want to
play the game no games those are data
points
so to that point to that point joe biden
is suggesting raising the corporate tax
rate
i mean how does that affect an economy
especially at a time
where we're certainly going to if he's
becomes president in november
or is elected in november how does that
help us
recover from this economic hit that
we've taken
you know if you look some of the major
investment banks goldman sachs for
example took a look at the biden of
economic plan and said it would raise
economic growth over the next few years
because it would do a lot more to
stimulate the economy
overall the tax plan would bring average
tax collections to about where they were
under president clinton the economy did
certainly
perfectly fine then um so i'm not
worried about his tax plan and i like
his overall
economic plan okay but i'll ask you
again more specifically
specifically about the corporate tax
rate in just a second but you look again
pre-pandemic trump economy
you had the unemployment rate in
february dipped to 3.5 percent in this
country
it's hard to make the case that this
president hasn't been
good for the economy you've got
businesses that feel
that they were in a very business
friendly environment
does joe biden's plan make or result in
a business friendly environment i'll go
back to my question about the corporate
tax rate
i mean when the corporate tax plan
passed the administration
promised we were going to get to three
percent economic growth
we fell way short of that for the next
two years after it's andrew so why
are you lowering the bar lowering the
standards i heard people on your channel
over and over again talking about three
percent growth three percent growth
he never got it he never got close to it
in fact he had growth rates lower
than we saw under the last four years of
president obama so i don't
think there was any type of you know the
economy was perfectly good before the
pandemic
grant you that nothing miraculous
nothing special
didn't improve after that kind of growth
are you forecasting for a potential
biden administration
i think we'll see a growth rate of
around two percent and i think we'd see
a growth rate of around two percent
if trump got a second term and that's
because we have a lot of demographic
challenges in the us economy
as workers are getting older and you
know that's just a fact that i think we
should accept the reality of
i didn't even get to any of my call
forwards here because if we got so into
that conversation we'll have to have you
back jason furman great to have you here
thank you